I mean I'm just kicking out right now
talking to you nah I'm just peaking out
right now hold me my comics I feel like
a kid
[Music]
I have a neon future tattoo I'm like
fully invested in a young future like
yeah and my album my albums are called
neon future my out by next album neon
future 3 the third chapter to my album
series it's coming out in November so
it's all timely right now with the entry
to the comic out now my fashion
collection called me on Futura so it's
like my brain is all things in the on
future four years the brand it's a brand
exactly and and neon future was a music
brand my music concept album yeah and it
needed a story telling narrative it
needed something to really kind of pull
out the juice from what neon future
means and and what a way to do it with
like incredible illustrations and
incredible storytelling through comic
book we have 18 issues we're like fully
developed so the first arch will be six
issues that will be dropping and then
we're gonna continue forward is it's
gonna be epic it's like the story is
that the characters in comics are
amazing they're absolutely incredible
and it'll like it'll like make you like
cry honestly like it make you feel
something what was your reaction when
the artist came back to you and this is
what he's like I'm still blown away like
I look at this I'm like you know like
today was the first day the first day I
actually have to like hold the comic
yeah this is uh it's more incredible
seeing this and like seeing my first
like album will be strong honestly like
this yeah this is it the different it's
a different world with me you know like
I'm a music guy obviously I I bencher in
different worlds but this is like a you
know another way to story tell this
concept neon future in a way that's
really exciting you know like so and
this comic is
it's steve aoki a character in the comic
well he's steve aoki this character
right here yeah he goes by the name of
kita Savita
okay which is the anagram of steve aoki
okay yeah which is what I came up with
out what I was 16 so I know strolling
and like doodling in my notebook he two
three trying to figure this out and I
can't believe it
yeah yeah I know it's just really it's
like for me like my thank you to see
Kelly I've used pieces be still 16 it's
like oh yeah that's like my alter ego
ever but now it's it's like yeah it's
like in comic book legacy so and ketta
savvy is like he's he's the guy we you
know we can all change to become like
yeah yeah he's like the he's like the
most human even though it's all it's
like very technologically the most human
element of the entire story the most
grounded in reality and neon Future 3 is
coming up what can you tease about the
collab that are gonna be on that oh god
it's like the most epic collaborations
I've ever done in my life I'm not
kidding Nicki Minaj is on three but like
wait look Brendan's in an article no I
know because I talked about talking with
Nicky about doing a song so that's yet
to be certain where that's gonna go run
yet cuz that's the future of the neon
future your future neo right well like
blink 182
Bill Nye field night all night that
sound well I mean that's the thing about
it near future it's about merging
science tech music you know like
humanity all into an album and you have
to wait to hear but he's on the album
Bill Nye is another artist on the album
so like a made of 70 songs
[Music]